-Welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is it.
Let's get to some news, guys.
I read that Jeff Bezos
may partner with Jay-Z
to buy the NFL's
Washington Commanders.
Bezos might be the only person
who has to stop and be like,
"Wait, do I already own
a football team?"
I'm rooting for Bezos and Jay-Z.
I never thought I'd say this,
but after the last few weeks,
I just want some
normal billionaires.
Don't you --
You know what I'm saying?
Can't they just be normal?
One of the big stories
today that I was reading
in the headlines that was funny,
Starbucks just rolled out their
holiday menu and their
25th anniversary holiday cups.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Everywhere.
It's everywhere, yeah.
We're so starved for good news,
we're now celebrating
the anniversary of a cup.
We're like, "25 years of a cup!
Oh, my God!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tariq, you see this cup?
Let me text you this cup news.
That's right --
Starbucks just rolled out
their holiday menu and cups.
They even released
a special message.
Check this out.
-The holidays are here,
and Starbucks
is excited to bring back
all your holiday favorites,
like holiday cups,
peppermint mochas,
Michael Bublé CDs,
holiday cups,
peppermint mochas,
Michael Bublé CDs,
[ Distorted ] holiday cups,
peppermint mochas,
Michael Bublé CDs,
Oh, my God.
It's only November.
What are we doing?
No, don't question it.
Remember, must use Christmas
to sell coffee.
So, happy holidays
from Starbucks.
-Oh, yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah! I love that.
Well, get this.
Today, Netflix launched
their new ad-supported plan
for only $7 a month.
[ Audience boos]
But this is interesting, though.
Apparently, some Netflix shows
have exclusive sponsors.
Did you hear about this?
I'll show you what I mean.
First up, "Grace and Frankie"
is exclusively sponsored
by Activia.
-Oh.
-You know,
it's exclusive to the show.
-Yeah.
-"Squid Game" is sponsored by
Black Friday at Best Buy.
I'm starting to understand it.
-Yeah, that makes sense.
-Yeah, next,
"The Watcher" is sponsored by
this photo of
Senator Mark Kelly.
You go, "Oh, wow.
Okay, buddy. Okay."
Next up, "Stranger Things"
is sponsored by...
October Kanye.
"Stranger Things."
-Wow!
-Next up, "Dahmer"
is sponsored by...
Impossible Meat.
-Oh!
-What?
-Wow!
-And, finally, "Bridgerton"
is sponsored by
Brookstone "Back Massagers."
For your back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Switching gears.
Last night at a train station
in Washington, D.C.,
President Biden delivered
a speech about
protecting democracy.
Yeah, normally, when a guy on a
train platform is yelling about
the country being doomed,
you just avoid eye contact
and keep moving.
Some more political news.
I heard that Florida governor
Ron DeSantis
is reconsidering
a presidential run in 2024
because he doesn't want to fight
former president Trump
for the nomination.
That's a bummer.
We were so close to a showdown
of Ronald versus Donald.
Speaking of elections,
the midterms are this Tuesday,
and there are several
key races around the country.
And while these races
can get heated,
it's important to remember
what the candidates
actually agree on.
Here, let me show you
what I mean.
First up,
John Fetterman and Dr. Oz
are facing off in Pennsylvania,
but they both can agree that...
Certain things you've got to be
able to agree on.
-Yeah.
-Next up, Blake Masters
is facing off against
Mark Kelly in Arizona.
They can both agree that...
Up next, in Nevada, Susie Lee is
facing off against April Becker.
They can both agree that...
"I'd just like to speak -- I'd
just like to speak to a manager.
Here's another one.
Angie Craig is facing off
against Tyler Kistner
in Minnesota,
but they can both agree that...
"Angie, there's no way
you're going to get this done
in three days."
Up next, Rudy Salas
is facing David Valadao.
They're facing off
in California.
They can both agree that...
-What?
-Next up, in Pennsylvania,
Matt Cartwright is
facing off against Jim Bognet.
They can both agree...
What?
-That's odd.
-And, finally, Raphael Warnock
and Herschel Walker
are facing off in Georgia.
They can both agree...
It's all bizarre.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, some entertainment news.
Yesterday, the new trailer for
"Avatar 2: The Way of Water"
was released.
And as you guys have
probably heard,
they shot the third movie,
as well, at the same time.
so, today, they released
a trailer for "Avatar 3."
Yeah, take a look at this thing.
-The way of water
connects all things.
The unforgettable characters
of Pandora return,
like Jake and Neytiri,
along with majestic new
underwater heroes, such as...
And introducing...
-That looks good.
Did you guys see this?
Elon Musk announced that
he's working with
Twitter engineers
on a reboot of Vine.
Yeah, that could be ready
by the end of the year.
When Viners heard
Vine might make a comeback,
they were like...
-Yeah, I sure hope it does.
-Meanwhile, kids who
only grew up with TikTok
are hearing about Vines
and thinking...
-What are those?!
-I mean, most people haven't
thought about Vine in a while,
so they were really surprised by
the news, kind of like...
[ Horn honks ]
Some people think Elon Musk
is making too many changes
over at Twitter
and getting carried away,
kind of like...
But most people are excited
for Vine to return,
so here's hoping Elon
doesn't mess everything up,
kind of like...
-[ Sneezes ]
-"Nice, Ron."
Well, listen to this.
Next month, a model for E.T.
used in the movie
is expected to sell at auction
for $3 million.
That's kind of cool,
but I don't know
who's going to buy that though,
you know?
I'm going to buy him!
Excuse me, sir?
I said, I'm gonna buy me an E.T.
I've been waiting
my whole life for this moment.
I can use that dang E.T.
for all sorts of things.
[ Laughs ]
Like what?
Well, I figure I can rest my
coffee mug on his head.
I can put a wig on him,
take a picture,
and make it my profile picture
on my MySpace.
[ Laughs ]
I don't think people use
MySpace anymore.
Yeah, I got all sorts of plans
for uses for an E.T.
I can put him next to the dishes
and make it look like
he's warshing the dishes.
[ Laughs ]
Oh! I can take him to
a baseball game,
tell the stadium
it's his birthday,
then get him on the jumbotron
and have it say,
"Happy birthday, E.T." on it."
And then, while everyone
is distracted wishing E.T.
a happy birthday,
I can steal a bunch of hot dogs
from the concession stand.
Then I got my dinner for
a whole year.
[ Laughs ]
Sounds like a plan,
but where are you going to get
$3 million to pay for it?
Well, don't worry about it.
Just check me out on OnlyFans.
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Finally, I saw that today is
National Sandwich Day.
-Yeah!
-That's today.
National Sandwich Day.
Hot-dog vendors were like,
"Do we celebrate this or..."